en plein cœur de Kiev des attaques
aériennes meurtrières depuis plusieurs
jours la capitale ukrainienne comme
d'autres villes du pays sont visées par
ces bombardements des attaques provenant
de drones que les forces ukrainiennes
tentent d'abattre des drones comme
celui-ci qui selon Kiev sont des shades
136 venus tout droit d'Iran une nouvelle
implication de Téhéran qui serait la
preuve des difficultés russes selon
volody mirzelinski nous devons nous
rappeler que le fait même que la Russie
fasse appel à l'Iran pour une telle aide
et la reconnaissance par le Kremlin de
sa faillite militaire et politique
pendant des décennies ils ont dépensé
des milliards de dollars pour leur
complexe militarro-industriels et ont
fini par s'incliner devant Téhéran pour
obtenir des drones et des missiles
plutôt balistiques
la Russie n'a jamais confirmé
l'utilisation de drones iraniens même si
Kiev affirme en avoir rabattu plus de
220 des drones guidés par GPS et
difficilement détectable même si ces
appareils ne sont pas toujours efficaces
car ils ne peuvent pas viser de cible
mobile Moscou recevrait même d'autres
types de matériel militaires en
provenance de Téhéran comme des missiles
seuls c'est en tout cas ce qu'indique
plusieurs médias comme le Washington
Post et l'agence Reuters il y aurait
même des instructeurs iraniens sur le
terrain selon le quotidien Le Monde une
implication iranienne de plus en plus
importante qui pourrait brouiller encore
un peu plus les relations entre Téhéran
et l'Occident business toute personne
exerçant des activités avec l'Iran en
lien avec le développement de drones ou
missile balistique devrait faire preuve
de vigilance
l'Union européenne a également affirmé
avoir rassemblé des preuves sur
l'utilisation de drones iraniens par la
Russie et prévient que des sanctions
contre Téhéran devrait être approuvés
dans les prochains jours